learning more about what led up to an  alleged a man allegedly throwing a baby  off of a balcony  it happened saturday near saint rose and  eastern metro police say 32-year-old  clarence martin jr threw his fiance's  two-month-old daughter  london from an apartment balcony the  baby died  police say martin set the apartment on  fire killing the family dog  police say martin drove away from the  fire causing two crashes on his way to  mccarran airport where he was arrested  according to the arrest report martin  had mental issues and hadn't slept or  eaten in three days  he's being held at the psych ward at  ccdc and is scheduled to be in court  november 10th